we're about to investigate how to make a
meal out of what we have here the first
I need some socks on my feet are code mm
socks okay what if we got what if I got
we got wine we got eggs we got mashed
potatoes carrots and strawberries I'm
kind of embarrassed about how so much I
don't know how about cooking I know how
to make salmon and I don't even have it
I didn't even get sin I was like I'm
gonna make me and Susie a nice salmon
mmm didn't make it
we've got chicken I think I'm on a break
man now so listen do you get the ball I
do
so we have do you actually know yeah
have you brought it have these fake
cockroaches where you brought oh yes
they said varela no I found them in my
purse oh so I'm gonna cook which I'm
actually gonna cook but I'm gonna put
the cockroaches look what do we do tell
me about this meat no no that's not that
okay we get what's coming like cracked
pepper where we just go with that we're
gonna make chicken not a pasta no no
we're on here spinach and kale ravioli
big chicken it comes outside yeah okay
well then you're you never eat your make
chicken before never like you just hear
that I'm gonna know what it looks like
what comes on the oven no I know where's
my spices hello just gonna say I washed
it too so it's like not gonna contain
anything
yeah I'm gonna wash it again before I
put it in the booth gonna be good
are you gonna be filming - yes we'll
just set one some more okay good okay
let's just scoop a little bit on covers
scoop a little to cover it and then
we'll just go ahead more this is
actually really good looks pretty nice
so are you - of everybody's hearts I
think this actually might be my my first
like home-cooked meal day long I think
this is my first home-cooked meal that
I've ever made myself this is incredible
thank you very much I walk on I know
you're boring as well but it looks
really good I gotta show you chicken
into mashed potatoes I know what to do
I think Jenna's going with it tomato
soup okay if I heard earlier no soup and
yeah it looks really good
thank you so much Jenna you're a really
good cook at pasta oh I got that
Legos come good Oh
where's your drug upstairs you know what
that's okay
hmm yeah dr. pol no question you I can't
believe what but this is a squat antenna
video that part was hilarious
I'm a very sweet dog like 200 high water
Thank You Ted hello look in the rag you
can leave a big ears oh it's gonna be a
lot easier for you your cut your tip on
me and mine did you thank you so much
well you look like a Neanderthal over
there I was just eating eat my chicken
with no saw you leave
I love marinara what's this thing well
my phone what is that yes I did wash it
so don't worry
uh yeah yeah yeah pretty man no I hadn't
noticed that was good was this the prank
you think oh yeah this is why I don't do
prank videos I'm not good at it I've
been thinking about this for five days
that was so clever
Wow but like just thinking about it like
if you don't watch my vlog like you got
I came down I came from upstairs I put
on a new shirt and socks and you guys
opened up the plate for me I was like
here you go here's your meal sir for you
and I was so I was like well thank you
so much
like it was so nice I felt really bad
you were so good like you guys were like
slaving away in the kitchen and I just
felt terrible because I didn't help and
I was so grateful and then you do that
I'm a dick I'm so sorry but I did wash
it it's clean and then when you were
talking I would back there cuz I was
dying laughing like I couldn't even keep
my my stuff together
I was just wanna I was just talking
about home-cooked no no no I felt really
bad
halfway through I did too I washed it
it's clean clean ha ha ha all right guys
I am NOT I can't prank I just you know
I'm just trying to get you back well
yeah it was clever though I'll give you
that
very clever if now if somehow you were
able to make it so that like a bee or
wasp was able to fly out of that you
hate bees
okay I want to have a drone bee honestly
huge thank you to Johnny Cupcakes
because johnny was the one that gave me
that original cockroach a long time ago
I don't know that is Johnny can't be
he's like the t-shirt company makes the
t-shirt Oh Joe fries loves those shirts
I love Johnny's great but yeah so thank
you yeah the food and either way all
right guys I'll see you later
we're probably do some more things
tonight so it is nice that's real nice
manis okay PJ Kim cuz I'm here
man great did Matty G get your
toothbrush you pack your toothbrush come
on let's go Bonnie ZBrush